welcome
everyone thank you for joining our
presentation titled
improving cell health for single cell
proteomic
analysis and immune monitoring it is my
pleasure to introduce
to you sean mckay ceo and co-founder
of isoplexes for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the tab at the
top of your screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions following the end of the
presentation
please join me in welcoming sean mckay i
will now turn the presentation
over to him hey
thanks very much for that introduction
uh
my name is sean mckay i'm the ceo and
co-founder of isoplexus
and i'll be talking to you today about
uh what we're doing in the world of
single cell proteomics and how
our technology is being able to be
utilized
to accelerate precision immune medicine
in a variety of ways
and finally how we view the concept of
cell health
and why sample prep is so important for
cell health
so a little bit about the company itself
we are very
precision medicine focused in terms of
what the
application of our single technologies
provides we're at a number of the top
pharmas we're at
um you know we're growing in our uses at
these uh clinical cancer academic cancer
centers throughout the united states
and we're really accelerating the
ability to provide
um you know the publications that folks
rely upon in our field to
to to then uh you know build the next
layer of their
uh precision immune medicine research we
have about 90 systems in the field since
we launched in
q3 of 2018 uh it's a
it's a system that's about a 28-inch
footprint and
you know generates these these single
cell readouts
in terms of what we're doing in terms of
what gaps we're specifically filling
we're of course well aware of the
ability to do
both high resolution single cell rna-seq
moving from the massive shift in
discovery from the bulk
to the single cells as well as using
highly multiplex flow cytometry for
surface markers
um but what we really focus on
um is uh assessing and detecting
the functional output or the functional
signaling pathways
of each of these cells and so you're
looking at a picture
on the right side of our screen what
we're able to do
and and this ends up helping us uh
access a sort of a different aspect of
the single cell market
than the traditional single cell
sequencing technologies what we're able
to do
is to assess the range of functional
proteins per single cell across
you know around a thousand cells per
sample
for example we have one chip family
called the single cell secretome
which allows us to look at 30 plus
cytokines
per individual immune cell um and that
helps us landscape
a variety of types of immune skills in
the human body or in our clinical
studies
we also have these intracellular
signaling chips which allow us to
interrogate
the the signal inside of the cell which
which uh uh you know we were able to
understand which proteins interact with
these proteins in a quantitative fashion
in the big leap that this is is has
allowed is
being able to move from platforms
looking at a few
proteins per single cell primarily being
blocked within the cell
um to be able to do many proteins of
these the functional nature per cell
again the secretome or the intracellular
signaling proteome
in the application is we've we've
seen in many data sets that um the
the ability to capture let's call it the
the
cells that secrete multiple cytokines
per cell in it
and and those cells themselves have been
the super powered cells
in a given subset um that have then
helped predict responses in the lagging
immune medicine
context we've also seen that the cells
that
are highly active rare cell subsets
let's say tumor cells that have highly
active signaling profiles
those have been affected with the
supervillains which help try
resistance and metastasis all the bad
things we want to try to sort of treat
the void with targeted therapies
so we've come a long way and you're
looking at a variety of these
publications on the left side of the
screen but
a lot of them have to do with um
you know uh generating an understanding
of how we utilize the immune cells
to be able to target more durable immune
therapies both with late stage
discovery and also pre-clinical and
clinical
um you know immune medicine again
using biomarker discovery tools um you
know
or be able to look at targeted therapies
and repopulate
signaling networks that are missed in
the bulk or with the rna
focusing on protein and protein
interactions per cell that
when reconstituted can understand um how
things are metastasizing
then again like this is a perfect
example resolving adaptive signaling
dynamics
and providing an alternative to genomic
profiling that can recapitulate
sources and pathways of let's say cancer
resistance that can be treated
you know importantly what we've evolved
to in the past few years is
a wider array of of installed systems
throughout the world just in a couple
years
has has allowed us to come up with you
know 50 plus predictive data sets
um in and around the world of
his immunology so as saying circulating
t cells or nk cells or monocytes
um you know in in preclinical or
clinical models
um in patients you know being able to do
that in infectious disease like covid
um sources of either inflammation or
durable response and finally
doing the same thing with a variety of
cell therapies going into solid tumors
or blood cancers or
looking at auto and aloe um and doing
the same in
inflammation um as well as these you
know as we
talked about targeted therapy areas of
cancer signaling pathways
but the the the most important sort of
connective dots between these apps
is that we're able to stratify patient
populations
and pick out the more durable response
populations early on
early on in the process to be able to
you know in a way that um is not able to
be assayed
side by side in these various published
studies with you know genomics or bulk
protein or
traditional flow surface marker based
assays and so
you know the uniqueness quotient of our
readout is
the the superpowered immune cells or
the supervillains of those tumor cells
that help
predict the overall orchestration of a
downstream response
um so importantly
um the applications continue to increase
on our platform
so we have two core families of apps
that you can think about we have the the
those that are the second cycloatomic
from each
single cell and those are called you
know immune landscaping
then we have the intracellular signaling
elements for a single cell and that's
the intracellular proteome and
metabolome
these are being released this year which
is again an exciting new application
that's coming out on our platform
um additionally we've now come out with
a third family of applications
that is what we call the codeplex apps
which
essentially are highly automated you
know
um super high multiplexed um ultra low
volume
bulk assays um but enabling a subset
of the subset of researchers to be able
to access
real time multiplex proteomic insights
on their bench
that they're not currently able to do um
so
what does this mean so what does it mean
that we're able to assay
all of these highly multiplexed
you know protein-driven cells so so
again it's that concept of
picking out the superpower biology with
superhero subsets or
these inflammatory you know kind of
super villain type subsets
and we want to in any of these immune
medicine
areas that represents of course a
tremendous opportunity for the world a
tremendous market for
both biomarkers and translational
development we want to target the right
durable immune t cells and k cells
balancing
an inflammatory response from so let's
say suppressive immune cells
and eliminating potentially hyperactive
malignant cells
to contribute to lasting immunity and
elimination of disease so this is
this is of course it's it's all all of
this landscape of various
subsets of cells driving an overall
response that you're missing
in the bulk this is contributing to
a durable immunity and an elimination of
disease
infectious disease and inflammation
and where we fit i think it's important
you know we're not really considered a
core discovery tool
really the massive movement and you know
from bulk to complementarily with single
cell
is you know we're really focused on
translational medicine
and that translational medicine output
has allowed us to to really harness
these powerful subsets of
immune cells and show that by
accessing this new data layer of each
immune cell the proteomic
functional proteomic data layer we're
providing
better paths to point towards
an increased efficacy if you can pick
the right patient populations with
various indian medicines
2020 has been a large year when you know
it marks the year
when our technology has been more
consistently mentioned
as a as a standard in at least immune
medicines
and you know this is in various springer
protocols with various labs putting out
methods on our technology
and us having the protocols for sample
preparation to back these up
this comes with various biomarker
opinion leaders highlighting
functional biomarkers and in our
technology in particular
as a future prognostic immune monitoring
is as well as looking in
the areas like coven 19 the circulating
immune response in the context of
building 19 as
you know to build upon the areas of
oncology and inflammation you focus on
in adding infectious disease is a core
application
for us so
it's important to mention how our
technology works
we have this isolite system that's a
fully automated proteomic workflow
we standardize the sample preparation um
going into the isolite um you know but
it's
all of the applications i mentioned is
one technology stack
inside the isolate and truly our
pushback software associated with the
isolite
is plug-and-play and we get
same-day insights via the data that's
coming out of the isolite itself
importantly each of these applications
we discuss
so the the functional landscaping and
the intracellular signaling elements and
the
highly multiplexed photo so the amino
assays
all of them who well published we have
standardized sample preparation
which involves essentially um if you're
using for example what most people are
using
um pbmc where let's call it cell product
you know there's a basic beat enrichment
step you stimulate the cells stain and
load
um it's very straightforward in a single
cell for for the automated amino acids
diluting the load so it's it's
straightforward but it but it also
relates to the point of this talk i mean
a lot of what matters coming into our
system
for single cell analysis is the quality
of the cell input
and we'll we'll discuss this as we're
discussing
the the the emerging needs for sample
preparation in our field
so one specific aspect of
um you know the the the com our company
is
you know the proprietary proteomic
barcoding that
we do and that we perform so if you
think about
uh the evolution in the innovation in
single cell proteomics that we provide
it all relates to what you're looking at
on this slide um and this is again
both our you know our intellectual
property but our
proprietary methodologies that make this
technology very scalable
throughout the world so first we have
this chip
that we've discussed the sample prep
going into
secondly within the chip we have these
micro chambers which
after sample prep you inject and these
micro chambers will see
you know 500 to 1500 single cells in
these microchambers
you you do get zero cell chambers which
helps at the background
you do get multi-cell chambers and it
sort of separates itself via poisson
distribution
but importantly you get 500 to 1500
single cells in these chambers
and the big you know innovation the the
kind of
the the thing that sets us part of being
able to do this highly multiplex
powerful t cell and immune cell and
you know monocyte work or these super
villain cell types is
we have parallelized the ability to
interrogate
these sandwich elisa based proteomic
outputs from the cell
across 12 000 chambers in parallel
and with it when a chamber has a single
cell what we're doing is
there's a cross hatching of these
antibodies that are laid down
you know vertically against these
horizontal
um chambers and that's basically moving
um in a in a consistent fashion in this
encoded glass slide which has these
proteomic antibodies which are
primary sandwich eliza's crisscrossing
each of these chambers
and each of these lanes represents um
one or two different antibodies and
what's
what ends up happening is the cell
secretes its proteins
the capturing antibody is is is
capturing the proteins
and then the flow cell is very fluidic
enabled so it enables us to just
flow out all of the cells in the
background
and then we we basically introduce
secondary sandwich elizas in an
automated fashion on the isolite in
those secondary sandwich elisa
antibodies
are attached to a fluorophore which then
tells us
in this spot in this concentration what
this cell ended up secreting
and so what we can do is we can end up
getting
30 plus cytokines per individual immune
chamber
and then we recapitulate that um to say
these are the subsets of cells that are
most highly secreting
and the way the phosphor proteomic acid
works is
we're effectively lysing the cell um
and that life cell then um basically
releases its phosphoproteins and
we capture those and the same process
happens where we say
these are the proteins that have been
activated in the coordinated signaling
network in that cell
so that is our our core
of of how we make the how we gather the
individualized cellular data
the isolite itself is an exciting system
because
it takes basically three elements it
takes
uh optics which are connected deeply to
the software itself
it takes fluidics which automate all
these elisa procedures
um within the chip itself and then we
have
software that's deeply connected with
the hardware
and what that ends up doing is we take
all of the traditional multiplex elisa
workflows
and we combine those all in our system
so that you essentially have a flow cell
you pick up that there lies a readout
it's all driven by the fluidics
you then have the optics which picks up
the sensitive signal
at a big gram per milliliter
concentration that goes from
you know two to five to two to five
thousand
um and then you have software that's
deeply integrated with the hardware
and it picks out that that readout such
that
this is what the software looks like
it's really push button
right and you're pushing buttons to sort
of isolate
various um sample differentiators
um functional differences and then
statistical differences
and it's it's actually really simple
once you use the software itself to see
how we're differentiating these patient
populations
by looking at the broad-based cytokine
readout or the broad-based phosphor
proteomic readout
and then clicking through to actually
pinpoint the biological drivers that
then differentiate various samples
in gathering insight that same day it's
very critical to realize
that um it's very critical to realize
that
um that we are
enabling um simple
uh simple uh simple transfer
of of the data from the isolate
down to the readout itself where you're
gathering insights
importantly the isolite is a benchtop
instrument it's a 28 inch footprint
right here
um 24 inch forward it's a benchtop
instrument
where you're installing eight chips per
run um and then you're gathering this
data going directly into
the software itself and again you know
you can access our website to get the
virtual demonstration of how the system
works
you can also access our website to get a
short demonstration of our powerful
software itself
so finally the question comes up as what
chips are we using itself
and what we're looking at is we're
generating a readout
in which we're gathering multiplex
cytokine information whether it's the
adaptive immune cells or it's the innate
immune cells
where it's again looking a little bit
differently but at the
inflammation driven by immune cells um
looking at all these different immune
cell types right here
for applications arranging around
the worlds of immune medicine
and i think just to remind ourselves um
we are
driving the fully multiplex separatome
of each single cell
and while flow cytometry of course is
well known for surface marker
characterization
just the limitation of blocking the
intracellular cytokines
in the golgi creates an inability to
highly multiplex in a reliable manner of
cytokines
and that the rna itself does not
translate directly to these protein
readouts that we see
so we're just going to briefly mention
the applications that we do but you can
you can think about the world of cancer
immunology
and see that we're able to and we're
enabling
preclinical choice via these unique
differentiators
highly active single cell immune subsets
with a variety of therapeutic types in a
variety of solid tumor or blood cancer
areas
we're also enabling early clinical
biomarkers again
with a variety of well-known trials in
checkpoint inhibitors or combination
checkpoints or vaccines
addressing a number of tumor areas um
with these various cell types
so so let's just look at a couple of
couple tissue oriented
um analyses that we've done this one is
looking at
tills and the core takeaway is
these patients when you are analyzing
the patients themselves
histological metrics or serum proteomic
metrics
were unable to differentiate patient
populations
in a statistical significant fashion
this means they were unable to
differentiate responders and
non-responders
now when you're looking at the response
of this is
just looking at tills or looking at a
variety of the multiplex both cytokines
or looking at all the multiplex both
cytokines together
but if you look at the tills themselves
you must assay that
multiplex secreted protein from each
till
you're able to see the responders
create this high degree of what we call
poly functional strength which is
multiplying
the percentage of single cells and
secrete multiple cytokines
times the intensity of those cytokines
and the non-responders
do not have these multifunctional tills
or
toes to secrete multiple cytokines per
cell so the superpowered subsets of t
cells do differentiate patient
populations
and it's a it's a very interesting
mechanistic readout
and it starts telling us learnings about
what can correlate to response as well
because this is a huge need in the
checkpoint inhibitor space
for understanding better immune
biomarkers
additionally if you look at a
pre-clinical study published in nature
um you know this the readout
the readout that we provided you know um
which was looking at tissues looking at
tills and mice and um
when you're looking at um basically
comparing the nectar 214 drug with
the wild type il-2 showing that there's
a more
robust potentially durable response and
again be correlated with persistence
here
um where the wild typhil2 is not driving
this persistence
the multifunctionality of these
individual mouse immune cells
seem even better here in this
polyfunctional heat map
where you see that the robust cells as
far as a percentage of overall cells
to create multiple of these cytokines
per cell
really they they don't exist they exist
more in the
um far more than nectar 214 than the
sort of wild type aisle too when
combined with
adoptive cell transfer versus melanoma
solid tumor
this was again quoted in genome web the
definitive readout
um you know this model system for this
this program
um again you know it it
versus a lot of the surface marker
phenotyping and
the gene expression assays that were
done so it's a functional assay
that we've created that it helps derive
some of these differences that are
critical
to correlating with things like
persistence
now what's important here and what we're
what we're going to close with is just
the idea that you know if you can
automate
tissue disaggregation that's really
important for the cell health
of the analysis that we're going into
and it's really important for a number
of single-celled home mix applications
but if you look at tissue sample you
know
what comes out of of of patient sort of
mice and you know
one of the core problems is just cell
health after this disaggregation step
and it's required we have to get to
quality sample input
for single cell analysis because we're
actually getting readouts from each
single cell
and that's that's what we do so just
just as
an example of what you can do with this
tissue tissue disaggregation
so if it's more automated you know
rather than sort of using a scissor base
based method what we saw is that
you know through manual methods you get
to you know a reasonable upregulation of
these multiple functional cells
but the cell health actually goes up at
the single cell level you get a higher
percentage
of these multifunctional cells two three
four five cytokines per cell
when you use more automated um tissue
disaggregation methods
and that increase of cell health by
improving the sample prep
is just an incredibly important next
step for our industry
and so um you know it's it's an area
that we're excited about and it's where
eric's and we're excited to continue to
collaborate about
and that that's how we view the the
field needs a more
productive ecosystem to enable us
to um generate the sample prep required
the data analytics required um around
our system and various single cell omix
applications
and the connectivity to basically
translational medicine
and reverse translational medicine to
using that information to drive more
targeted therapies
and better more durable immune medicines
as we move forward
so thank you very much for your time and
i'll now open up for questions
thank you sean for that truly
outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
and our first question is what other
cell pipes can be measured with
isoplexus
single cell proteomics
so this is sean hi did you guys see me
on the video
just to be sure do you guys hear me
yes right so
um really we focused a lot on
application this video i miss in this
presentation um but but we're looking at
a range of cell types you know the
single cell
tone applications we have including
natural
cells mos sites
adaptive subtypes um that the utility of
harnessing these proteomically driven
uh superpowered cell types
can can be extended to
again if
large study of coding patients are you
know driving
with a drop in nutrients so really the
the multi-helmet capacities enabled by
you know ability to look at others all
types i think
uh gather a lot of um stability and also
research impact around the single cell
continuum
i think the other
just does briefly some applications
where really watching
in earnest in the november and december
period
and you know one of them is the
profiling of
the intracellular uh mix as we like to
say for the
the first time we're seeing the complete
intracellular pathway
of true protein per single cell and you
can imagine that any targeted
therapeutic which would be
equipped
that that's sort of the series of the
cell types
that we're looking at um imagine any
um range of these cell types in the
human body
thank you sean
all right and it looks like we have time
for one more question
um can isoplex's technology also look
at intracellular proteins simultaneously
yes indeed you know the interrogation
of the cellular proteins is this
next family of applications for
launching into that period
really people know us
that we have the ability to interrogate
this how the immune systems functionally
communicate with all these types which
for the first time
very exciting this is new we think
unlocks a whole layer of breakthroughs
in discovery
um which is in the same chamber-based
platform i talked about
today you have the ability to license
the cell and interrogate the
intracellular components
in a way
we're introducing metabolomic connectors
in those pathways
and if we start to understand things
energy state activation and you know the
use of
multiple targeted therapies to not just
treat the first pathway
but to engage the likely resistance
a technology instead of looking at a few
intracellular
things per cell or proteins in the book
which is the range of intracellular
proteins that matter
zero in on the heterogeneous cell types
eventually they are driving some of that
metastases
so it's really a breakthrough
application
thank you so much sean and i it looks
like we have a little bit more time
here um one more question here
has poly functionality correlated
with response in other areas of research
and if so where and in what disease
and therapeutic areas
sure so so we look at two cell types
um two cell states there's
probably speaking the effector cell
types on the immune side
are called the good actors or the
superheroes in a given cell uh
we've shown a lot of work now in the
allergenic natural killer cell we have a
publication in cell stem cell
which shows that an allergenic and
natural killer cell therapeutics that
you know those correlates from the poly
functionality scores
to longer term persistence in various
levels
so that's an interesting one cell paper
today really focuses on
very clear if you read it you know again
we have three
three components in the main figures but
there's this monocyte
um if you just look at the frequency
as well so it's just it's and that's in
covenant 19 and
uh one of the largest coding patient
studies that is
you know cellular and multinomic in
nature um coming
from the um providence health seattle
consortium
with institute persistence biology work
so
really you know we've shown in t cells
a lot and now really in case
we have multiple high impact journals
showing some of these mechanistic and
also
persistence and also monocytes now are
beginning
a much bigger role of course in
infectious diseases
and like i just described but also in
the world
of cancer as well because we published
another
paper
disease and various types lymphoma
patients that was in blood cancer
journaling last year
really showing the breadth of this
highly called functional readout in the
importance
across cell types
thank you again so much sean and
unfortunately we are out of time for
today
don't worry any questions that were
submitted and not answered today by our
um fire speaker will be addressed via
email
and thank you again sean into the
audience for your participation
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months
and please remember to share it with
colleagues who might be interested in
today's topic
and i also don't miss out on other
presentations on our agenda
and visit the agenda tab in the
auditorium
for a full listing thank you again for
your participation
and until next time